[Music]
mikey is with us get us out of this
mikey he's in indiana how can we help
hello how are you
good how are you
pretty good um i'm a junior at indiana
state emerging and business
administration and mining
entrepreneurship cool good for you my
name is yeah i want to start my own
business um
i'm taking the finance class right now
that we are learning at real estate and
how to manage money
but i'm struggling with what my
professors teach us because it goes
against their free principles
that i believe in and learned in
financial peace class in high school
like for example some of the things that
he says is that we should use credit
cards for everything sure so you get
money back and can't rent a car or hotel
or buy airline tickets with a debit card
or cash yeah he also said uniquely like
a credit score in order to buy a house
and if you ask him about dave ramsey
he'll tell you dave ramsey's an absolute
idiot
oh yeah
yeah that's fine
yeah and then he said we should take our
equity in our house buy new cars he also
said that payday lenders and cars are
necessary you need to pay for something
so here's the thing mikey
he's a finance professor
okay he doesn't have any money
you're getting a degree in
entrepreneurship
and one of the things is you have to
learn to think critically
and how to avoid these situations
okay
so
what do you think the odds are that
you're going to change
anything he believes or teaches i would
say close to zero wouldn't you think ken
uh yes guaranteed i don't think there's
anything that you can do or say or i can
do or say that are going to change
this guy's misguided
bad teaching
and bad advice she's going to continue
to do it okay
is that you believe that to be true
mikey he's going to continue to do it no
matter what we do agreed
true okay so now you got to decide
now you got to decide are you going to
pass the class or not
yeah i have an a in that class just pass
the class and move on
okay because you're not going to change
the guy and you're way too smart to
follow what he's saying you know he's
wrong you've got good critical thinking
skills you've compared his advice to
what you've learned from us and his
advice came up short
and you found our stuff to be the truth
my joke always is is that i learned to
borrow money from my finance professor
in college who was broke a finance
professor that's broke is like a shop
teacher with missing fingers
i've been telling that joke for 25 years
and it still gets a laugh yeah it's
still funny because that's exactly the
case here so
here's a funny one mikey get this so my
daughter denise ramsey
at the time she was not married at the
time was taking a personal finance class
in college
and the guy not only did everything that
you're talking about but he always spent
five to ten minutes every class
trashing dave ramsey not realizing his
daughter was sitting in the room
wow
and at the end and she called me and
she's upset and she's angry because she
wants to defend me and i said darling
just pass the class but at the end of
the class make sure you introduce
yourself
and she said when she introduced herself
at the end of the class she got an a
because she answered his questions the
way he wanted them answered
it didn't change her opinion she's never
borrowed a dime didn't change anything
and then she introduced herself at the
end of the class and said i've been
sitting here
for the entire time listening to you
trash my father
but i wanted to make sure that you knew
i was here
and that you gave me an a and i wanted
to thank you for the a
and she said the guy almost threw up
he almost lost it he almost lost his
cookies right there so i mean that you
just got to have some fun with this dude
because it's you're not going to change
anything those convinced against their
will or are the same opinions still
sweet little denise
because she she's non-complicated she's
not like rachel she's
non-confrontational
rachel would have been standing up in
the middle of class having a heyday
right there and we'd have to get her
you'd still be reading headlines we
should still be reading headlines like
her father
she would make the tennessean